rich where are you right now I am in the
radio booth where the Steelers radio
team will be doing their broadcast
tonight where I'll be doing my radio
show from today I'm told but this is
where Myron cope it is did his craft for
so many years right here in Heinz Field
it's pretty neat man it says quiet I
mean we were one of the only few people
in the stadium it's gonna be a good one
tonight you could feel it already
whether it will that be an issue oh my
it's a slate graze guy Dan with the wind
blowing off the confluence with a bite
to it I mean this is this is from
November football there's no there's no
precipitation but we will not see the
Sun all day today
it just looks nasty and is gonna be
bitter it's going to be one of those
fields like games when when they kick
off tonight I'm trying to figure out
this Steelers when the Steelers are at
home and they play a good team they
usually play up to that level when
they're on the road they tend to play
down to their competition does anybody
have an explanation why the Steelers can
be this great but also this much of a
question mark quad oh no I would beg to
differ a little bit there Dan I think
that Jaguars are a really good team this
year and the Jaguars came in this
building another AFC South team last AFC
South FEMA came here and hit them in the
mouth and they kept hitting them in the
mouth until they knocked him out with
that you know 90 some odd yarder that
that Leonard fournette ran and they're
there the Titans coming tonight tied
with the Jaguars so it's a big game for
them in that division so they this
dealers against the Colts last week I
mean I watched that too and you just sit
there scratching your head like why
aren't they blow the doors off this to
you yeah but maybe just maybe that that
that one typical quintessential classic
Big Ben play where you know Ben's that
quarterback rare quarterback for whom
the play starts after he's head usually
the play ends when a quarterback his hit
but it usually begins for him where
people draped on a my
I saw you did that highlight on on
football night in America and you you
you called it perfectly like people
draped on them throwing it he found a
Antonio Brown for a big play those are
the types of things that maybe just
maybe kick starts a run because well I
mean there's seven and two but I mean
the the Patriots come in this house in
December that Steelers defense was no
joke on Sunday night football against
the Lions where they just never let him
in the endzone in the red zone I believe
in them I think they win tonight and and
eventually we'll just be talking about
the first half of the season is an
aberration I saw an article that said
there could be as many as 11 NFL coaches
fired seems like a pretty big number
they're rich that's a very dark black
Monday by the way it's by the way it's
New Year's Day this year
is the fur is the Monday after the NFL
season so we'll see how many happy new
years it really is so that's a lot I'm
just even thinking in my head right now
where that possibly would be double
digits I mean the the rumors I'm hearing
are you know obviously Cleveland and
Indianapolis in Chicago you know here's
the other day in San Francisco McAdoo go
for it so you got the Colts the Browns
the Giants and Tampa Bay now this was on
the big lead that said there could be 11
NFL coaches fired so that would be the
four under the heading put the house on
the market dirt cutter Ben McAdoo Hugh
Jackson Chuck Pagano in trouble Marvin
Lewis and Cincinnati Todd bowls with the
Jets it's been ugly but they might
survive Adam GaSe in Miami Bruce Arians
Arizona John Fox Chicago Mike McCarthy
Green Bay Bill O'Brien Houston I I mean
if I had to nitpick there I'd say Fox is
in a lot more danger than this and this
article is saying that I think hmm you
know it's a copycat league and I
you've seen what coaching can do for a
young quarterback coming out of college
with the Los Angeles Rams I think
everybody's going to want themselves a
Shaun McVeigh in the same way that
everybody in baseball is looking for
their AJ Hinch and Dave Roberts right
now I think everybody if you're under 35
and are an offensive genius for your
team coordinating I think you're in good
shape for forgetting your first NFL head
coaching job and that that might be a
spot in Chicago you know so but I don't
know about the tampa either i know that
they've always had a quick trigger
finger
if Gruden really wants to come back yeah
and would go back there I think Kurt
cutter would be done but I don't know if
they're you know if they're gonna do
that but then again like I said there's
still a lot of football left to be
played you need to see how it all plays
out at four and six Todd Bowles does not
deserve to be on a hot seat in in New
York he's done a great job I think with
a with a bad hand that was dealt and no
quarterback even though he is you know
playing well he's he's ancient there's
no other way to put it so I would beg to
differ with some of those but in terms
of you know the Colts and the Browns and
certainly the Giants that be concerned
to from their coaches he's rich Eisen
from the NFL Network tonight on NBC and
the NFL Network it will be the Steelers
and the Titans yeah I look at dirt
cutter and the reason why you might be
expendable is if Jon Gruden is available
I think that's when you make the move if
that's the case but you know you talked
about this with Gruden I believe where
you know his Tennessee a possible and
like he gives vague answers with this
with Mike and it feels like he's playing
us here and it feels like his agents
going now let me call John skipper and
see if we can up that contract here do
you think Rudin coaches I mean I do I
mean I heard it in his voice
he I think he does at some point where
he's in his mid-50s right now his kids
are getting older as you know he's got
one already you know it looks like
Popeye it was the strength coach of
Washington I think he wants to coach
and I think if he does get an
opportunity to company in a spot where
he can help be the the man shop for the
groceries being charged get a long-term
contract and give it one more time I he
sounded like that to me you know flat
out said that I'm gonna keep my options
open which is definitely koi but you you
tell me do you think he's got a contract
with ESPN where where any time he feels
he can call them up and say I'm gonna
leave so you better give me more money
I mean yes that would be a rarity right
in our business I've never heard of
something like that where where I mean
he could obviously go and just say I'm
out of here and coaching again but I
won't do that as long as you give me
more money right now that would be that
would be a very interesting contract I'm
he's in a position he's in a position of
power
he's Monday Night Football and I think
you know he probably says look I'm gonna
continue to do this as long as I love
doing this but you know there might be
that time when I decide I believe he had
all the cards here to be able to say
they were desperate to try to find you
had Tirico and you had John that was a
great team now Tirico leaves does he
still want to do this and do it with the
new partner in Sean McDonough I think
that's really the biggest question here
with Gruden if he doesn't enjoy it as
much is he going to then look at college
or the pros in a different way and I
believe that's what's happening with
with Jon Gruden well when he was on I
asked him if he brought up his ffv a
inspired football coaches of America
that he he founded and he makes up
t-shirts and hats and you know the last
time I spoke to him a couple years ago
he was running that out of a small
office out of the back of a Publix in
some tampa strip mall and I asked him if
he's still behind the Publix and he
laughed and then started describing some
Taj Mahal type place that he's built
with football field and and what sounded
like a half dozen film rooms where he
literally is always breaking down film
like he's a non-stop film junkie which
to me sounds like again somebody who
still
wants to coach loves the film and and
you know Mary he's not here tonight but
when he's with us on Thursday Night
Football and you know he's one of the
sweetest guys I've ever met and he is
gonna empty-nest now he's a grandfather
he loves doing what he's doing with us
at the NFL Network you get him out there
on the sidelines and he gets his hands
on his hips hands on his knees bending
over looking down the first down line
slapping it their officials putting his
hands on coaches you know I mean it's in
their blood it's in every last coach's
blood who goes and does what we do for a
living and he just sounded to me like
he's into it just but maybe not this
year I don't know if he'd do it for
college honestly I don't want to speak
for him at all because I do not know his
mindset whatsoever all I know is what he
had said and sounded like with me when
he was on last Friday and he definitely
sounded like a guy who'd be interested
in the right spot Rich Eisen working
tonight double duty the Rich Eisen show
following this one on DirecTV it's an
audience Channel 239 and then part of
the pre half and postgame coverage there
of Thursday Night Football yeah you left
Daniel you left out the pre pre once
again just think of me watching you with
a cigar in your and my Snuggie and
fireplace and I am I may have pants on I
may not but just think of me as you're
doing the show tonight but it's all
appreciated nonetheless hey you're a
team player I want to ask you about this
since you are mr. Beverly Hills mr.
Hollywood
we had Anthony Anderson he's got the
show blackish hit show yeah Fritzie came
up with the show years ago we do think
that blackish stole this
Fritzie came up with Jewish how do you
can we pitch Jewish on Network I think I
can I don't think you can oh no Fritzi
can you know fritzy can
ready all right let's just let's do this
if you really want to try but all right
fritz I I am the buyer okay I'm running
the network all right I've been in these
pitch meetings dan you've been in these
pants meetings okay where you're trying
to sell a show okay I'm I am I am the
buyer you have 15 minutes with me let's
condense
what's your opening line to pitch me the
show Jewish fritzy the elevator pitch to
Rich Eisen is rich
everyone's Jewish in Hollywood we all
know that the agents all the ones making
all the decisions so they're already
half in the way you reel them in you've
got this family of neurotic Jewish
individual the customs and laws they go
to Temple only on the High Holy Days as
many of us do and therefore they are Jew
yes yeah there you go
are you in yes oh you got that built-in
audience to say hey they're talking
about us okay great I don't know if I'm
at the time you know the holidays are
coming up my championship a yso game is
coming up that I'm coaching on Saturday
I don't know if I have the time but I'll
look at it
you send me an email what is a PDF for
me I'm gonna look at good we were
thinking of the Irish that we're gonna
do a show called irony the fighting
would be into that
I read all right well let you go you got
other things to worry about have fun
today and tonight and talk to you soon
all right Rich Eisen NFL Network Rich
Eisen show on DirecTV on htlm 239 for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on Direct
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]